what's going on people in this video
we're breaking down the finale for part
two of Attack on Titan season 4 in which
Aaron finally shows up for the first
time since the rumbling began during
this episode we got flashbacks to
various things that happened while the
scouts were undercover in Liberia and
today I'll be explaining everything
including how mikas had the chance to
stop Aaron wiping out Humanity before we
get into it though don't forget to
colossal smash that sub button so you
don't miss future Attack on Titan
breakdowns as part 3 is confirmed to be
coming out in 2023 this poster for part
3 was released online soon after the
episode aired in Japan and if I had to
guess I reckon next year we'll get
around eight or nine brand new episodes
that will finish off the series for good
I don't think there's going to be a part
4 for this season but I mean the way
they've stretched it out over this many
years who knows maybe they will be but I
highly doubt I think part three really
is the end
anyhow getting back to episode 28 the
title for this one was the dawn of
humanity and it begins with a bird
flying overhead even though it's only a
small thing the bird appearing in this
opening does have some significance as
it directly relates to mikas narration
in this narration she comments on how
people seem to think Aaron has changed
but in reality it's possible that he's
been the same person ever since the
beginning the reason this relates to the
bird is because in Aaron's mind the
walls were nothing more than a bird cage
that took his freedom away which is why
he hated the Titans even before his
mother was eaten years later when he
finally escaped the bird cage and
ventured outside he realized that he
still wasn't free since their enemies
across the sea were just another bird
cage restricting his freedom once again
therefore by doing the rumbling this is
his one chance to become truly free for
the first time and it's why you could
argue that his core motivations have
never changed the CNN flashes back to a
year earlier when the scouts were
heading towards Mali by ship and for a
bit of context I'm going to quickly
explain what's happening during the time
skip between seasons 3 and 4 the scouts
were actively looking for alternatives
to the rumbling because they didn't want
to rely on it for their survival relying
on the rumbling would mean the Historia
and her descendants would need to become
Royal but at Titans and to avoid that
outcome hanji suggested they should
travel to Mali by going through with
this they could learn a lot more about
the enemy and hopefully find a solution
and that's why episode 28 follows
directly on from this because this is
their first time leaving the island
they've literally never seen things like
clowns or ice cream or cars which is why
Hardy started waving at it like it was
some kind of farm animal
While most of the group was visibly
excited to be here from the start of the
episode Aaron had a depressed look on
his face and often looked like he was
indeed thought about something the main
reason his mood was so terrible compared
to everyone else was because he's
realizing that all these people and
everything around them will one day be
wiped out because of him back when he
kissed his story his hand he saw future
memories of his full-scale rumbling but
for a few years he let himself believe
that this future might be avoidable
Aaron had initially hoped that freedom
could be achieved a different way but
after trying and failing at this point
he was 90 certain that the memories he
saw were going to happen that's why he
consistently had this vacant expression
since he was processing the reality that
he had no other option but to destroy
everything he's currently looking at
it's interesting when we contrast
Aaron's gloomy expression with armin's
excitement because from a young age they
both had this dream to see what was out
there but only one of them is burdened
with this knowledge of the future now
before we move on I thought it was worth
mentioning the significance of Aaron and
mikas's early interactions on two
separate occasions he was in a complete
trance thinking about the terrible
things that he's going to do and both
times Mikasa shows up to break him out
of that thought process in my opinion
this was foreshadowing for later in the
episode when Mikasa had the chance to
break him away from the reality where he
does the rumbling in this one moment
Aaron was willing to go down a
completely different path but it all
depended on how Mikasa responded to his
question later in the video I'll explain
exactly why this was the case but for
now I just wanted to highlight these
early interactions which was subtly
laying the foundations for what was to
come
anyway soon afterwards Levi gets
pickpocketed by a young Refugee who
tries to steal his bag of coins if this
boy's face looks familiar to you it's
likely because he appeared very briefly
in episode 19 during the many visions
that Aaron saw as he entered the pause
dimension in this flashback Levi grabs
his hand to stop him running away with
the money and the local Marlins in the
area start to surround them given that
malians aren't exactly the most tolerant
people they start berating Ramsay not
just for being a thief but also because
he's an immigrant from another country
this is evidenced by the fact that they
start to discuss the various cruel ways
that they'll punish him including
throwing him into the sea or smashing
off his hand it goes without saying that
these type of brutal punishments are
things they never consider doing if it
was a fellow Marlin that was caught
stealing but because Ramsay is an
immigrant they view him as less than
themselves in a similar way to how they
view aliens one of the people in the
crowd even mentions how Ramsay might be
a subject of Emir which gets a reaction
out of Sasha and a few other Scouts
seeing the cruel way the boy would be
treated Levi picks him up and makes up a
flimsy excuse about how the refugee
didn't technically steal anything
because the money belongs to his older
sister who is apparently Sasha although
nobody believed that it's used it at
least gave the group some time to run
away and eventually they managed to
Escape From the Mob that was surrounding
them by the time they arrived in the
secluded area everyone was exhausted but
sitting on top of these ruins was Ramsay
who'd stolen the money for the second
time today as he cried tears of
happiness the captain decides to let it
go since that money was just given to
him by the asthma Beto the scene ends
with Aaron staring in Randy's Direction
with a blank expression on his face and
not for the first time Mikasa realizes
that something isn't quite right with
him moving on the group then arrives at
hisru's estate and kyum explains to them
about the improvements in blood testing
Tech we already knew from Kruger's
backstory that blood tests were used to
determine if people were subjects of
Emir and kyomi reveals that this Tech
has got an even better making it easier
to find aldians who've escaped from the
internment zones the reason the
Ambassador was telling them this was to
make it clear how difficult it will be
for parodies to form any sort of
friendly relations with other nations
because their people are being
systematically discriminated against all
over the planet
despite that Armin and hanji were still
willing to work to find this peaceful
solution since historia's future depends
on them finding this alternative the
Commander goes on to explain that the
next day there's a political Forum in
which an association called the subjects
of emea protection group will be giving
a speech judging from their title it
sounded like they might be willing to
cooperate with parodies but at this
stage of the episode the scouts didn't
know what the group actually believed
the plan was to listen into their speech
and if they sounded friendly then the
island would try to make contact and let
this group know that their intention is
to make peace this was pretty much their
final hope of finding a diplomatic
solution because if they couldn't make
allies with this Association then the
chance of them making allies with anyone
else is virtually non-existent after
that Mikasa notices that Aaron left
while kyomi was talking and after
everyone goes to look for him she finds
him by himself outside this refugee camp
although she didn't see it he was crying
before she arrived and this is proof
that right now Aaron is mentally at his
lowest point and is questioning whether
the rumbling is something he wants to do
remember when he spoke to Reiner earlier
this season he revealed that he used to
think everyone in Mali was an enemy but
it was once he crossed the sea that he
realized that they were all the same
while there are bad people here who
discriminate against aldians there are
also good people here too who don't
deserve to be trampled this is something
Aaron only understood once he got here
and it's why for this one single moment
he was willing to abandon everything and
run away with Mikasa as she approaches
him he goes on to explain that these
refugees are similar to The eldians in
that one day their regular lives were
taken away from them and now they have
no freedom following her a brief pause
Aaron turns to mikasan asks her why she
cares so much about him from the very
first episode it's been obvious that she
loves him in a couple different ways she
loves him in the sense that it's her
responsibility to keep him safe almost
like a parent but at the same time she
does love him in a romantic way as well
this has been demonstrated on many
separate occasions some more obvious
than others but for the most part Aaron
has rarely demonstrated any romantic
feelings back that's not to say he
doesn't have these feelings but rather
he's terrible at showing it and up until
this point he's treated her more like a
sister than a potential girlfriend in
this sequence though he asks her the
question because he wants to see if
she'll reveal how she feels about him
and in his mind if she admitted her love
then he was willing to abandon
everything rambling all these innocent
people is something that he wasn't 100
ready to do yet and he preferred to
spend his remaining four years with
Mikasa regardless of what happens to the
island however when it came down to it
she was afraid to tell him how she
really feels and if you've ever been in
a remotely similar situation then you
can empathize with with why she didn't
tell him the truth keep in mind that in
this scene both of them are still
teenagers and so confessing your
feelings is embarrassing is risky in
case the other person doesn't feel the
same way and she was kind of happy with
the way their relationship already was
for a decade they've been best friends
so to add romance to that equation will
have unknown consequences and cause me
because it didn't have that long to
think she played the safest option and
told him that she sees him as family as
an audience we can tell this wasn't her
true feelings as she was visibly
blushing while staring into his eyes but
at the end of the day she just wasn't
ready to say how she felt for that
reason she couldn't give Aaron the way
out that he was looking for and From
This Moment onwards the future he saw
became set in stone
the rest of the scouts that arrive is
Ramsay's grandfather invites him inside
the tent and throughout the night they
have a pretty great time drinking
together having fun and eventually
passing out
these festivities were the one time
Aaron had a smile on his face as it was
the last night he spent with his friends
before abandoning them to go undercover
in Mali as a side note in episode 27
John himself had a flashback to this
same night when he realized that it was
impossible to save these refugees from
the rumbling the next day the scouts
attend the speech from that pro-elden
political group in hopes of forming some
kind of Alliance but as the speech
continues they quickly realize that
that's not gonna happen to put it simply
this organization is seeking to defend
the rights of displaced aliens all
around the globe with an example being
people like Annie's dad who were taken
away from their home countries his
argument is that these refugees have
nothing to do with the alien Empire and
shouldn't be punished for those crimes
as it's the Devils on the island who the
world should hate following this logic
there was no hope of the scouts ever
coming to an agreement with this type of
group and as a result this was the day
that Aaron walked away from them despite
hanji's best efforts there was no
peaceful solution to defend parodies and
so Aaron Left Behind letters for his
friends telling them that he was
trusting everything to Zeke as we now
know he was only pretending to follow
Zeke so that he could Rumble the entire
planet instead but he wasn't going to
put that in a letter for obvious reasons
the next time Mikasa saw him was during
the attack on Liberia after he massacred
tons of innocent civilians and this
helps to give context to why she was so
upset when she finally saw him again in
the narration present-day Mikasa wonders
if all these things were destined to
happen from the start or if things might
have turned out differently if she'd
chosen another answer on the day that
Aaron asked her the all-important
question
the episode then moves on to Aaron's
perspective in the clouds as his massive
founding Titan continues to charge ahead
during his narration he begins to wonder
where this story started as it's
possible it began with the dream he had
under that tree in Chicago or maybe it
began 2000 years ago where one of these
pigs managed to escape eventually
leading to yamir becoming the first
Titan alternatively the story might have
begun when he was born or as he said in
the previous episode maybe Grisha is the
one who started everything however in
the narration he comes to accept that it
doesn't matter where this all began
because the fact is the story isn't even
over yet even at this late stage all the
characters of some kind of future
waiting for them ahead regardless of
whether it's good or bad and this
narration is early acknowledging that
there's more they have to go through
before they reach the end point
things then flash back nearly a year ago
when Jelena first told them about Zeke's
euthanization plan flock is the one who
enabled this meeting to happen which is
why he was listening in and she goes on
to explain that the tainted wine was
consumed by high-ranking people in the
military this is how flock knew all
about the wine well before anyone else
and he was able to use that to their
advantage when the Yeagers made their
move to take over
some time after this the two Scouts that
had a meeting of their own in which
Aaron told him how they should pretend
to follow Zeke's plan flock was
initially confused about what pretending
to follow the plan would achieve and
this is when we switch over to a
different flashback which partially
answers the question in this other
flashback we see Aaron talking to
Historia before the scouts leave to
visit Mali and he warns her that the
military police are planning to turn her
into a Titan to be specific the MPS
wanted to make sure that she is Zeke as
soon as he steps on the island and
Historia was more than willing to go
along with that plan as long as it
remained necessary for the island
survival for Aaron though he wasn't
prepared for her to make this sacrifice
and so he was willing to pretend to
follow Zeke's plan because it might lead
to a future where she and the rest of
his friends can live full lives this is
when the scene switches back to flock
and it shows us the moment when Aaron
spells out his plan for Global genocide
by betraying Zeke this massacre will
become possible and it's interesting to
take a look at Aaron's facial expression
as he says this during this moment he
clearly has a lot of anger and
conviction inside him which is a huge
address to how he felt when he
physically arrived in Mali and saw the
things that he'd actually be destroying
moving back to Historia after telling
her his intention to do the rambling she
begins to freak out but despite her
hesitation he's ultimately able to
convince her to stay quiet about the
whole thing Aaron needs historious
cooperation for his rumbling plan to
work because if she didn't help him then
Zeke would have been eaten as soon as he
got to the island it was specifically
because she volunteered to get pregnant
that the Yeagers had the time they
needed to overthrow the existing
government but the question then becomes
why would she do this in one sense Aaron
Historia are very similar people in that
they were both willing to sacrifice the
world for someone they care about in
season 3 Historia had a chance to eat
Aaron and inherit the founding Titan and
she was told that by doing this she'd
have the power to save Humanity from the
pure Titans Aaron believed this was true
as well which is why he asked her to
kill him but in the end she rejected
that power and saved his life even
though it meant that humans in the walls
might be wiped out by the Titans in the
present day Aaron is now essentially
repaying the favor by sack sacrificing
Humanity itself so that his story can
survive but it was only possible because
of her cooperation
the episode flashes forward to the
Jaeger Brothers conversation in Mali and
this is the third time you've seen this
conversation but every time we do see it
we learn something new this time around
Zeke is playing catch by himself while
teasing his younger brother as he
confirms that mikas's love for Aaron is
out of her own free will and not because
of Any Ackerman DNA for whatever reason
Aaron theorized that her desire to
protect him was somehow related to him
Awakening her power but as it turns out
that has nothing to do with it and the
headache she gets are completely
unrelated in spite of that Aaron still
went back to the island and told me
because they're a bunch of lies because
in his mind it was better for her to
stay away from him and live a full life
than for her to be involved in his
rumbling plan we then proceed to get a
flashback within a flashback as Aaron
can be seen in the trenches in the
Middle East by this point he had
infiltrated the Malian Army and was
among the soldiers who were sent to
fight the Mideast Alliance and in this
scene he demonstrates just how strong
his conviction really is with no choice
left but to follow this path he
agonizingly soars off his own leg with a
knife so that his what injuries seem
more realistic without these injuries he
likely wouldn't have been allowed to
stay at this Hospital in Mali so it had
to be done if he was going to follow
through with this
after soaring off his leg he then
plunges a bullet into his left eye
partially blinding himself in the
process and honestly I'm not sure which
of these is worse if I had to choose I
think I'd go with the leg soaring option
just because I don't think I could do
this even if the world depended on it
but at the same time it is a quicker
option
anyhow the flashbacks progressed so one
of Ramsey getting beaten up in an alley
by some of the merchants but admittedly
it's hard to tell what's happening here
without looking at the manga panel of
this exact same moment over the
narration Aaron then reiterates to Zeke
how he wants his friends to live happy
lives as the anime shows us this final
flashback in which the scouts had a meal
together the night before they retook
wilmaria in this image both Marlow and
Commander Evan were killed by Zeke the
next day which makes it kind of ironic
that this image appears on screen as
Aaron is telling his brother how he
wanted them to live happy lives
regardless episode 28 finally returns to
the present day immediately after this
as this massive Fleet of Warships from
all around the globe has gathered to
stop the rumbling these ships are the
biggest and best the humanity has to
offer and due to the nature of the
thread a ton of countries have joined
together to make this happen as the
steam from the Titans rapidly approaches
this guy gives the order to Fire and
surprisingly it seemed like these
weapons were actually working the first
wave of Titans was chopped to Pieces by
these cannons as their body parts began
seeking lower into to the water however
with barely any time to think a new wave
of Titan swims through the madness and
was heading straight towards the ships
the fundamental issue here is that even
if every one of these cannons was
guaranteed to kill a Titan the fact is
that there were thousands if not
millions of them within the walls so
humanity is simply way too outnumbered
in this situation
one of the best sequences of the episode
came straight after this with the Titans
quickly swimming underneath the ships
and as they did that the steam they
produced was so intense that it
literally melted the people on board the
force then caused these warships to be
catapulted into the air in a scene that
was reminiscent of Almond's colossal
attack on Liberia this time though the
amount of ships destroyed was on a much
larger scale and as they exploded into
the ocean it created a sort of light
show for everyone watching on the shore
most of the soldiers that abandoned
their positions to run into the City and
as some of them turned around they get
to see Aaron's enormous bony shifter
emerging from the smoke this imagery of
him leading the rumbling was heavily
foreshadowed during the opening for part
two and in this scene one soldier
screams in horror declaring that this is
the attack Titan we then get a close-up
of his new Titan face and generally
speaking it is similar to his regular
shifter appearance with the key
difference being that he has lips where
he didn't used to and his hair is now
significantly longer and less human
looking while Aaron marches forward he
channels the anger he fell on the day
his mother got eaten Because by
dehumanizing the enemy it makes it
easier for him to kill them throughout
this video we've established that Aaron
knows that humans are all the same no
matter which side of the wall he's on so
the reason he thinks back to this rage
is because it's helping him to push
forward and do what needs to be done in
that Spirit he mentions how he's going
to wipe out every loss one of them from
the world and this is a call back to
when he said the same thing about the
Titans after she died part 2 then ends
with an aerial shot of the rumbling
wiping out an entire city and the final
shot of this episode is one of the time
stomping on the camera which is
identical to what we've seen in the
opening for part two
anyway people that was my breakdown for
the finale of part two of the final
season I want to thank you all for
sticking with me for these first two
parts I really appreciate all the
comments week to week and of course I
will be doing these reviews when part
three returns next year in the meantime
I'll be continuing my series on what if
Aaron got the Colossal Titan and doing
other videos for both Attack on Titan
and a couple other series too for the
next few weeks though I'm going to the
US and likely won't be uploading again
until I get home so be sure to turn on
notifications so you don't miss my next
upload when I come back until the next
one peace out